[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what is
president of the Russian Federation
Vladimir Vladimir Putin
People's Republic
head of logansk People's Republic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
solder
[Applause]
assigning the agreements between the
Russian Federation
People's Republic
thank you
foreign
People's Republic
[Applause]
Russian Federation
[Applause]
Russian Federation
[Applause]
People's Republic
[Applause]
ANS
People's Republic
[Applause]
region
region
[Applause]
as part of the Russian Federation
of new
subjects
[Applause]
[Music]
national anthem of the Russian
Federation
is being played
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a rather surreal moment there as
Vladimir Putin and the russian-backed
leaders of those four regions luhans
Ukrainian regions luhans donets zaparita
and herzon
sign a document to Annex those four
regions as and as Vladimir Putin said
create four new subjects of the Russian
Federation let's go now to our Moscow
correspondent and magnesia's in the Red
Square um
don't know what do you make of what
we're just seeing now
well you hear the Russian national
anthem and these accession treaties
signed with as you say the Kremlin
appointed heads of those regions which
aren't actually completely controlled by
Russia in any case either politically or
militarily it is all to cast an air of
solemnity and legality to what President
Putin is doing which is effectively
annexing 15 of his next-door neighbor's
territory in what is the largest land
grab in Europe since the second world
war with the biggest land grab before
this being the annexation of Crimea
there is nothing legitimate or legal
behind this annexation but what we have
just heard from Vladimir Putin for a
long 45-minute speech was really an
attempt to justify to his people but it
is Russia who stands there in defense of
Traditional Values against a marauding
aggressive West who is out to try and
Destroy and break up Russia